well I guess my view on this important
issue is that if you're going to be
eating pizza you might as well also have
Fried Chicken on top of the
pizza Bloomberg news reporter Sarah
frier joins us now via Skype with more
of the highlights and Sarah this is the
second public Q&A that Mark Zuckerberg
has done we've seen over the years him
get much more comfortable handling some
of these questions from the public why
is Facebook doing these Q&A this way
well he actually answered that question
a little bit in the last Q&A he said
that he some doesn't like the fact that
a lot of his communication with users
happens through journalists or analysts
journalists who who likes journalists
right so so he he really wanted to have
an opportunity to connect with people
directly sort of the way that Facebook
does in their regular Town Hall meetings
that they hold with employees where
anyone can come ask a question and then
it's just really
um as open and honest as they can be can
you talk to us about the structure of
the q&as does he know these questions in
advance does Facebook select these
questions he definitely knows some of
them in advance and and some of the
questions were certainly prepared people
flew in to ask the questions from
various uh states and countries and um
you know were there just in Mena park at
Facebook headquarters just to ask the
question so and the rest of them he
asked open ly on the thread on his
Facebook page uh for people to to you
know give whatever whatever questions
they wanted and other people would
upvote them and you know the most pop
some of the most popular ones were
answered Sarah um I was also really
intrigued at his sort of thoughtfulness
around this notion of a dislike button
which anyone has ever seen something
when tragedy happens in a family a death
or whatever you want to show your
sympathy you can't click the like button
but he's thought this through and the
the negative implications that that the
ramifications of such a a button might
uh have on his business yeah he really
doesn't want to create any reason for
people to to cause more negativity on
the internet he really wants to have a
positive experience for people on
Facebook so a dislike button doesn't
make sense because he thinks that that
would use uh people would use that to
downvote other people and say you know
this this post is stupid right but an
empathy button or maybe something for
those situations when a family member
dies or somebody posts a a important
story about something that's just you
know socially or culturally sad uh he
wants people to be able to react to that
in a Way Beyond comments but they
haven't quite figured out how yet so
that might still be to come and I do
want to share a couple more of his
answers he was asked specifically about
parenting and and whether kids under 13
should be using Facebook take a listen
to what he had to say if you have a
platform that is an an that is anonymous
it's a lot easier for people to do
harmful things to other people than if
you're using real name and if you're
connected to um a lot of other people
who are also using their real identity
in the community um but I think to
answer your question um I would follow
our rules so we don't allow people under
the age of 13 to use Facebook so I
probably so I would not allow my child
under the age of 13 to use Facebook and
then after that I would probably talk to
them about
it so he wasn't asked when he himself is
going to have children which I know is a
question a lot of people have uh the
other interesting question he got was
about mistakes he made early on is there
anything that he would have done
differently take a listen to his answer
to
that the mistakes that we've made in in
um in running Facebook and building it I
mean there are many and I started off
when when I was so young that I didn't
know anything about building a company
or a product or any of this stuff and
I've learned so much from the people
around me and um you know making
mistakes is a lot of How I Learned so I
guess just you got to keep on powering
ahead and and don't stress too much
about
it he got a lot clearer there all a he
he did he did get a lot clearer
messaging I mean l Sarah what do you
make you know of his answers just to
some of these questions does it seem
genuine to you well yeah I one of the
questions I've always had about these
Tech Executives who have created a new
way for people to communicate is whether
they ever have these moments of of oh my
gosh I've created a monster right when
they see like the cyber bullying that
happens on Facebook and he did he did
point to that so I thought it was
interesting for him to say you know
follow the rules no kids before 13 he
kind of has to say that but you know
when you think about children in
technology don't ban them he said
Society is sometimes a little too
overbearing with children in preventing
them from becoming used to technology
and literate with it he reflects on his
own adolescence and how much technology
helped him get where to where he is
today and he felt like he was pretty
proficient and he understood it so so he
he really doesn't like that Society has
this idea that that people should be
banned but of course he can't say that
children under 13 can be on Facebook
because that's the rule